- Ah! Il est arrivé!
- Kim Thuy est émerveillée
par les progrès réalisés
en quatre ans par Valmond.
KIM THÚY, mère de Valmond
- C'est magique!
(rire)
C'est sûr que si on pouvait
scanner la tête, on verrait
comment les neurones se sont
connectées.
- Son fils peut maintenant lire
des mots. En cuisine, il est
devenu un chef d'une redoutable
efficacité.
- C'est comme si on était
en train de voir émerger
le vrai Valmond.
- L'approche développée par deux
Québécoises permet aujourd'hui
à Valmond de mieux communiquer.
BRIGITTE HARRISSON, Centre
d'expertise en autisme SACCADE
- Ça fait en sorte qu'il est de
plus en plus capable de parler
pour lui-même, d'arriver à dire
ce qu'il veut, ses goûts,
ses choix.
- Il y a quatre ans, Kim Thuy
disait que son fils était
autiste non verbal.
Son vocabulaire se limite encore
à une dizaine de mots,
mais aujourd'hui, Valmond
réussit à se faire entendre.
- Bien c'est ça! Mon Dieu!
Ma vie est trop belle!
Je sais plus quoi dire!
- Lors de notre dernière
rencontre en 2017, Valmond
commençait à peine à reconnaître
certaines sensations,
comme la fatigue ou la faim.
Aujourd'hui, c'est lui
qui planifie son menu du jour.
- Vous allez voir ce qu'il veut
ce soir. Il a vu le pot de pâte,
donc ça va avec le fromage.
Donc ce soir, c'est ça que
je veux. C'est déjà planifié.
- Valmond a même trouvé
une façon de commander des repas
au restaurant.
- Il a découvert le poulet
St-Hubert et Benny à l'école.
Il savait pas comment nous le
dire. Il a rapporté un jour
le papier pour nous le montrer.
Il l'a collé sur l'armoire.
Il vient puis il nous montre :
"commande-moi..." C'est lui
ou l'autre, il connaît
la différence entre les deux.
C'est extraordinaire, hein!
- Il manque probablement
de mots, mais il manque pas
de trucs par exemple
pour se faire comprendre.
- Ça, on le met ici?
- Oui.
- Avec la communication,
ce qu'on voit arriver,
c'est la flexibilité,
c'est la planification,
la résolution de problèmes.
- Ça fait plus que baisser
l'anxiété, je pense que
ça apporte du grand bonheur,
tout simplement, d'exister,
hein. De ne pas savoir comment
demander de l'aide, ça doit être
incroyablement difficile. Et là,
il est capable d'identifier,
capable de le dire. Il voit
les solutions. C'est magique!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Kim Thuy répète souvent que
son fils prend maintenant
le contrôle de la cuisine.
- Là, j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous
faire le gâteau aux bananes,
sauf que Valmond, il sait que
ces bananes-là, elles sont pas
prêtes pour le gâteau
aux bananes. Donc...
(rire)
T'sais, oublie ça! On fait pas
de gâteau aux bananes.
Avant, je disais qu'il était
non verbal, mais maintenant,
il est verbal dans le sens où
il utilise... Il a pas plus de
mots, il a peut-être 10 mots
dans son vocabulaire,
mais il utilise le bon mot
au bon moment, c'est-à-dire...
Il s'assoit souvent ici pour
manger. C'est la place la plus
confortable. Et avant, s'il
n'avait pas assez de sauce, il
va se lever, il va me demander
de l'aider, mais physiquement.
Alors que maintenant,
il s'assoit comme ça
puis il me di : sel.
Il me donne un ordre!
(rire)
Mais j'adore ça, c'est parfait!
LISE ST-CHARLES, Centre
d'expertise en autisme SACCADE
- On peut pas prédire qu'il va
devenir un grand orateur, nais
qu'il ait au moins le bagage,
les mots pour exprimer ses
besoins toute sa vie, c'est
énorme.
- On a collé "sel"
puis j'ai testé pour voir
s'il comprenait vraiment ce que
ces symboles-là représentent.
Il sait maintenant que la langue
écrite représente un objet.
- Puis ce déclic-là,
vous l'expliquez comment?
- C'est un travail de longue
haleine. C'est un apprentissage
d'un langage.
- En 2017, Kim Thuy nous
expliquait comment le cerveau de
Valmond fonctionnait de façon
statique, comme un enchaînement
de diapositives.
- On dit souvent que
les autistes sont rigides, mais
ils sont pas rigides, ils sont
statiques parce qu'ils prennent
des images, et non pas en film.
Donc pour eux... Valmond,
il passe devant, il a pris
une image : la tangerine,
elle est à droite de la tasse.
Mais là, si je déplace et que
la tanguerine est ici, puis là
je lui dis : "Valmond, donne
à maman la tangerine", ça lui
prend du temps parce qu'il doit
reprendre une autre photo
puis dire où est la tangerine.
Puis là, il faut qu'il décode.
- Mais avec les années de
travail, les images dans la tête
de Valmond s'enchaînent
beaucoup plus facilement.
- Et là, maintenant, sa tête,
elle est capable de se déplacer
avec nous. Je sais que c'est
difficile d'imaginer qu'une tête
ne bouge pas, qu'elle est
statique, mais pour
les personnes autistes, très
souvent, c'est ça la difficulté,
c'est d'avoir ce mouvement-là
dans ses réflexions,
dans sa pensée et...
bien, c'est ça, dans son
interprétation de la réalité,
du quotidien autour de lui.
- Souvent, les gens pensent
qu'un diagnostic d'autisme,
c'est une fin en soi,
mais c'est un début de parcours.
- Brigitte Harrisson est
elle-même autiste. Avec Lise St-
Charles, ce qu'elles enseignent
à Valmond, c'est une façon de
mieux vivre avec sa condition.
- C'est le même parcours que moi
j'ai fait, mais je suis partie
d'un peu plus avancée que lui,
c'est tout. Alors c'est la même
chose. Ça permet d'avoir
un accès plus intéressant,
je vous dirais, à la qualité de
vie entre autres, et pour soi
et pour les gens qui sont
autour de nous.
- Avec le temps, le travail
permet à Valmond d'avoir
une meilleure qualité de vie
à la maison et une plus grande
autonomie à l'extérieur quand
il sort prendre des marches,
par exemple.
- Alors avec la marche, au
début, je pense qu'il ne voyait
qu'un bout de mon épaule. Là,
il marchait toujours derrière
moi puis de temps en temps,
il avait besoin de toucher
mon bras pour savoir que je suis
encore là et il se mesurait
par rapport à moi. Et là, on a
travaillé ensemble avec Saccade.
On le fait marcher vraiment
à ma gauche, et apparemment,
ça l'aide vraiment beaucoup à
absorber ce qui se passe autour
au niveau visuel. Mais après
quelques semaines, pas seulement
qu'il l'a vu, mais je pense
qu'il a vu plus que juste
mon bras, mon épaule. Il n'a
plus besoin de toucher mon bras.
Et aujourd'hui il peut marcher
à gauche, à droite, devant,
ça ne lui dérange plus.
Puis je vois qu'il voit
maintenant, puis il dit: oh mon
dieu, il y a tout ce beau monde-
là autour de moi que je voyais
pas avant! C'est fou, hein?
- Valmond démontre qu'il a la
capacité de réaliser encore plus
de progrès, de lire encore plus
de mots, de mieux communiquer
ses besoins, ses intentions.
- On espère aussi qu'il va
pouvoir avoir une suite
au-delà de 21 ans.
- Car après 21 ans, c'est
la famille qui doit prendre
en charge tout le soutien
dont un autiste a besoin.
- C'est comme si on disait
aux diabétiques : à 21 ans,
vous n'avez plus d'insuline.
C'est la même chose.
C'est exactement la même chose.
- On répète et on répète : il y
a pas d'âge pour faire le
travail avec la personne
autiste. Là, Valmond arrivera à
21 ans, mais on le répète, à la
clinique, il y en a qui ont 75
ans.
- On continue, on n'arrête pas.
Donc, je suis en train de
planifier pour après ses 21 ans,
pas seulement pour Valmond,
mais j'espère pouvoir le faire
pour ses camarades de classe
avec qui il a grandi.